yes god bless you dr. Wallach how are
you doing today
well fine thank you for the kind were
sir and since you're doing very well
what can we do for you today
I have I have a prolactin oba so base
brain tumor oh it's actually EB eat it
it eaten it has eaten part of the inside
of my skull and the bone behind my nose
oh also I had my gallbladder taken out
to the head go by his own and they
suspect I've had too much more roughly
about 20 years and I'm 17 years old and
I'm about a good 200 pounds overweight
oh how tall are you I'm taller I'm sorry
about five four and three-quarters
okay and how many shoe my last weigh-in
was 364 yesterday but I've been taking
I've been taking some of your products
so it helped things a bit away all right
now do you have any history of skin
problems eczema dermatitis psoriasis no
sir
any asthma bronchitis asthma yes ok ok
sure what's the underlying problem here
he's got a gluten intolerance and that's
why he's got a weight problem because
he's not able to absorb nutrients never
absorb nutrients that can absorb
calories right smart yeah sugars are
small they're easily absorb a tie for
I'd like to see it for a guy I'd like to
see wait Oh 140 150 so essentially we
need lose about 120 pounds here no no
more than that 220 or something like
that yeah 200 200 yeah okay exactly
all right what would you do for this
young fella here Charmaine I would well
really really needs I mean it really
technically needs 4lt brain and her
packs however that's gonna be pricey
yeah so yeah if there's a price issue
here you can start out with two yeah
okay I wouldn't go any lower than two
celebrated hard packs
what you do because he has gallbladder
removes all he needs to take the enzymes
gallbladder in a bottle ultimate yeah
ultimate enzymes gallbladder in a bottle
all right
and then analyst for the way to the
weight he needs at least two bottles of
the rose okay good and then you say this
brain tumor is a malignant tumor has
been been there for 20 years they
predict yes they diagnosed be almost 10
years to the day today
are they giving you chemotherapy or
radiation I mean most malignant tumors
kill people if they're gonna kill you
they're gonna kill you in a couple years
so how did you get away with 20 years
God okay that's a good answer
I'll buy that oh okay I've been taking
very old natural supplements for quite
some time now of right before I get that
a little bit up to now okay so again
just quickly to healthy brain and heart
attacks per month minimum if you can go
for three it's better yet you can go for
four that's better yet but a minimum of
two healthy brain and heart attacks per
month full dose for everything at least
two times a day better you have three
times as a better at four times a
whatever your finance they'll go
I'd give yourself two bottles of the
gallbladder two bottle of chartres says
that's the ultimate enzymes go ahead and
take two of those before each meal with
a couple ounces of water like two
minutes five minutes four weeks for me
with a couple ounces of water also get
two bottles of Rev I wouldn't take any
less than that to take a dropper pull on
your tongue during this week's meal a
dropper full under your tongue the
second driver pull under your tongue 15
is for each meal who are two bottles and
months to do that limit absorbs are old
tissues you'll begin to lose a half a
pound to two pounds a day and let's see
here what would you do how would you get
the ORAC points up chart to deal with
this brain tumor he could take the take
the beyond tangy tangerine 2.0 tablets
yeah the bgt 2.0 tells you exactly right
and I'd go ahead and take two of those
I'd go ahead and take two though
oh no let me back up let's take for
those three times a day be three bottles
a month take four of those three times a
day okay I get your auric points over
400-thousand me about 460,000 that's
pretty close to what I take I only weigh
150 I take 500 thousands a day just for
prevention and that's going to support
your immune system which is gonna be
your best friend obviously you're doing
well let's see we can't make things
better give us a call every two weeks if
you would hear Everett and we'll walk
you through this and be great for people
to kind of track and see how your junk